ai program predicts what last selfies on
earth will look like so
horrifying images of what the last
selfies taken on earth is from the new
york post may look like have been
depicted by an ai image generator take a
look at some of these pictures the
haunting images which look straight out
of a hollywood blockbuster we're posted
to the robot overlords tiktok account
which provides daily disturbing ai
generated images you could scroll down
and see some of those images
okay wait wait wait wait wait wait
timeout a robot that what this thing
thinks for itself no no these are
ai generated images artificial
intelligence images
of what the end of the world is going to
look like basically
and it's like look at take a look again
at the beginning let me see that dude
that is look at that [ __ ] so first you
know my thought on this first of all i
told you i'm afraid of the robots so
that looks like some type of terminator
situation going on but keep buying the
technology people
don't ask questions you want the
terminator coming to your house we don't
have a john connor last i checked
unless it's you i don't know how i'd be
here never know i am armed so you are
well there you go
but you know i see this [ __ ] and i'm
like why are we a morbid people a why
why do people need to see this see i
feel like people have a little bit of
morbidity to them they're like they
enjoy this idea of thinking about what's
gonna happen
we gonna die are we gonna be taking over
are we a morbid people my grandmother
used to read the obituaries for fun like
is that part of just humanity 100 we
like it's funny your time with just just
us as a species we're we are jacked up
disgusting
we really are no i was telling her was i
telling her in the roman days like i
don't care like this really happened
they would fill up an arena with people
they'd have people kill each other then
they'd like the winner would stand there
they'd open the door and the lion would
come out and eat them and people cheered
like we love like i'm not going to front
there's i watch world star world star
hip-hop it's on my app i scroll down
they don't give a [ __ ] judd they put
anything out there and i hate seeing it
but like one guy was um
cutting some guy's hair uh and a guy
comes in shoots the guy and the barber
backs up and the barber has a gun and
shoots the guy like six times and i
can't really watch it but the views on
this thing are you can't watch it but
you have to watch you have to watch it
people are stabbing each other and it's
just like bro we're it's in our blood
it's in our dna we're we're insane i
just love this type of death destruction
is like you worried about the robots i
gotta ask i mean you know i know you
said you're worried about you what is
that what did you want us to pull up the
all the balls
oh yeah
i think it's called boston there's one
that looks like a dog that's the one and
it looks it looks like it's a fake video
the thing runs like a dog and it really
pisses me off it bothers me
the biggest thing was if elon musk
missed her technology launching [ __ ] you
know what he said i'm this is going to
be the biggest mistake he's warned us
guys slow down yeah he's basically said
i i think it was called trans
transcendental man it was a documentary
this guy's like he was on the cutting
edge of all this [ __ ] and uh all these
he was pro ai look at that those things
dude come on man my transformers are
right now i had a i had a nightmare that
that yellow one was chasing me in my
dream and i couldn't get away and it
grabbed me and i felt metal on my leg
it was horrible but the documentary
transcendental man he's going for this
technology because he wants hopefully in
the future like bring his father back
it's a really trippy one but the the
scientists the real guys are like do you
understand
this thing is going to be smarter than
anything like a million billion times
more than your little brain and it goes
the same way that you look at an ant you
see when we see an ant and you go down
and you kill it you don't think twice
this thing who's to say this thing's not
gonna look at us and like yo get the
[ __ ] out we're we're in charge and once
they start thinking for themselves
they're gonna
that's where the scary scary part is and
it could get hacked it's a machine
exactly so it's like you see what goes
on with computers everyone's like oh
yeah it won't get hacked what do you
mean it won't get hacked somebody's
manning that machine there's got to be
somebody behind all that controlling it
and initially when this came up i
remember everyone be like oh it'll be
great for the military and i'm like is
it though is it like then what happens
if the military goes rogue what if the
command what if the leaders of the
military you never know what if you know
they're fighting somebody and they lose
control of x y and z and now it's in
enemy hands i mean you've got to think
like i don't understand did nobody watch
television growing up
you're seeing this stuff manifest now
some of this dystopian stuff some of
this robot stuff like you got to be able
to look at the stuff and be like you
know what we're good we don't need to
advance everything to the point of like
this is why i'm telling you man i talk
about it here all the time get me a
delorean and send me back i can't i
can't take it anymore
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode
right here
[Music]